covid
so the big thing that i'm seeing very
frequently is people are talking about
well cases are skyrocketing again which
we should talk about
but the case fatality rate is actually
flat or down which is interesting
and i think we should talk about what
the meaning is in one sense i don't
understand why this surprises anybody
we botched the lockdown and having
botched the lockdown
the second wave was absolutely
predictable and many of us predicted it
so let's just say um i think probably
all the viewers and listeners will
understand this but
when we are saying we in this case we're
talking very much as
uh as american as american citizens you
have the united states of america
not across for the most part the rest of
america and certainly not across the
rest of the world
the united states uniquely [ __ ] this
one up
really bad really bad and in some sense
worst of all possible worlds because
what we did
was we went maybe 70
of the way to an effective lockdown
which caused
everybody to grow thoroughly tired of it
and many people to rebel against it
without getting
much of the benefit at all just enough
to uh destroy
large sectors of the economy to uh
impinge on everyone's mental health many
people's physical health
and to make everyone so exhausted with a
thing that it is at least
one for sure of the factors that led to
the protests that then became riots
in the streets starting the beginning of
june yeah and it also i mean maybe you
could argue that this is actually a
positive thing but it revealed the
um double standard that exists inside
our sense-making apparatus where
everybody was demon
demonizing one set of protesters and
giving another set of protesters a pass
for
um for being out there and not social
distancing
now of course we have to put this in
context
those protests occurred outdoors
outdoors appears to be
relatively safe for the moment we have
predicted that that will decrease over
time but for the moment outdoors seems
to be a
safe environment now of course as we've
talked about before we don't know if
it's safe during
the day because of uv light we're safe
all the time due to the
volume and air flow and therefore never
crossing the threshold of viral load
that makes people sick
well i think we know we actually pretty
well know that both of those things
are protective do explain part of why it
is
so much safer as to almost be actually
completely safe to be outdoors during
the pandemic that
increased airflow because
density of viral load is completely
predictive
of whether or not you get infected and
also of how sick you get once you do get
infected both of those things
and also it's true that sunlight does
destroy this particular virus as it does
many others
so and so we would expect that there
will be some less protective
effects of being outdoors at night but
that those effects will certainly not
disappear entirely because i don't i
don't have a sense of
of those two factors i'm sure there are
more but of those two factors
basically increased airflow being
outside and sunlight being outside
which of those you know if i had to put
percentages to how important they are i
don't honestly know
well here i'm going to do my famous
english to english translation service
wow okay that's usually my job right
it's also your famous english english
translation service so in this case what
i would argue is that we have a model
and we should all be building
models based on what we understand and
our models were really cruddy at the
beginning of covet and we were all so
worried about washing our hands and
touching surfaces which
is important but it turns out for this
particular virus it's not nearly where
the game is the game is
all in this other realm um or almost all
the the key though is
for reasons that are yet to be fully
articulated you have to cross some
threshold of the number of viral
particles that you encounter
immune systems with a non-specific
response seem to be able to deal with
some number of these things
and so a conversation of a minute or two
even with a sick person
is unlikely to cross that threshold a
five minute conversation
is much more likely to a five minute
conversation in an enclosed space that
captures all of those particles so
they're all
unable to diffuse away makes it even
worse and if you're outside
you've got to think you've got a bucket
that you're filling with viral particles
and if you cross the top of the bucket
you get sick
but the bucket is being emptied by the
uv light which is killing viral
particles at some rate so the bucket and
by the airflow
well the airflow means that the bucket
isn't filling very fast because they're
diffusing away
and they're also dying right the uv
light is killing them and so those two
things are removing these things
it's the concentrating environments that
make you much more likely to get sick
and it's the
environments that dispel or kill these
things that make it much less likely for
you to catch it
and people are both so poor
at understanding these nuances and being
educated so badly by the media and by
scientists
uh that for the most part we are falling
into as i've been saying
since almost the beginning these these
tribes these you know star belly sneezes
and sneetches without
and so you know we see now when we when
we when we go out
that there are people wearing masks and
you know in the state of oregon where we
live it is now mandated to wear masks
inside
um and uh and outside
um and there's a new twist to this as of
yesterday but outside
mostly people are not wearing masks
which is a legitimate move
and yet you can also see in the eyes of
people that they are judging you
uh and assuming that if you're not
wearing a mask you're one of those
people who doesn't ever want to wear
masks and that's not to say that any of
us want to be wearing
masks but understanding the necessity of
wearing masks when you're inside with
strangers
is very different from imagining that
mask wearing every time you leave your
home is necessary
so let me say that on a next door which
is
you know this this uh app that will be
familiar to many people it's this sort
of
neighborhood connection device uh just
yesterday we had uh someone in our
neighborhood post
with regard to a several hundred acre
park that's very near us
i walked in the state park today and i
was disappointed that 50 of people were
not wearing a face covering if people
can't or won't wear a face mask she
wrote they should not use trails it is
selfish and reckless to not wear a face
covering on a trail please walk on
neighborhood streets instead now i
responded
for the first time ever on nextdoor you
know carefully and respectfully
and uh and got many thanks for it and
the original post has since been pulled
down
uh but you know again this points
to the lack of nuance
in someone's understanding one of the
things i said in response to her was
we we should not be imposing rules that
are neutral
or even unhealthy for people certainly
unhealthy for people with
you know everyone is suffering some
mental health effects from this you know
months long lock down now and some
people with physical problems
are going to be impaired if they have to
wear masks will not therefore go outside
if they have to wear masks to do so
and will be further impaired as a result
of that and
imposing bad rules on people is going to
make
many good people less likely to follow
all rules which includes not just the
bad ones but the good ones as well
that is the opposite of what we want i
totally agree with this and i am
experiencing i
probably experience it a little bit less
because my version of a mask
is some sort of signal but still not
wearing it results in people even when i
know
that my model is quite good and it's
actually based on
data in as much as we have that yeah
there is a sense of like oh you're one
of those anti-mask people
and and let me just remind people who
have been tuning in more recently that
we started these live streams on march
24th
and our very first one we talked about
mass this is before
the who this is before the surgeon
general had said oh oops sorry our bad
that was actually a political move not a
scientific one it turns out masks are
useful after all we just have a shortage
so you know we we were advocating for
this before the mainstream
if anybody's pro-mask it's us but but i
think you know i really want to
emphasize what you just said
it i've landed in exactly the same place
which is that there is a missing
category here which is
okay that person's anti-mask they're not
wearing a mask even in close quarters
okay i do think that there's some shame
that belongs there unless there's a very
good reason that they're not wearing it
right and then there's the pro mask
people who are now broadcasting that
they're a pro mask in circumstances
where
you should take a break and you should
not be wearing your mask because you
need a break
and then there's a third category which
is people who are operating
a high quality model of the infectious
problem here and they are using their
mask accordingly
right and so that category needs not to
be shamed
by the always pro-mass people even if
they're going to be always pro-mask
and you know i've heard at one point joe
rogan
you know he was in comedy mode and he
was joking about people who drive around
with their masks
and it was funny but i also know i have
especially in the early days of this
driven around with my mask
not because i was afraid in the car
alone that i was going to get an
infection or that it was going to blow
in the window
but because before we understood that so
much of this is airborne and it's not
really about surfaces
there was a question about touching your
mask in order to
pull it up and take it down and so you
know if you had two stops that were
close together or if your mask is
comfortable enough
then the point is oh you just leave it
up it's not that much of an imposition
so somebody with a sophisticated model
should not be shamed by anybody
yeah so and yet here we have in oregon
where uh
in indoor mask use in any public space
is required as of
i don't know a week or two ago and as of
well i think it might be tomorrow um but
the order came down yesterday
uh wearing masks outdoors is required
by law at risk of fine uh if you cannot
socially distance by six feet
now there there's a lot in that caveat
of course if you cannot socially
distance by six feet
uh but you know to this to this woman's
concern
about people going out into nature and
hiking several miles without a mask on
trails where they may at some point
cross paths with someone else no
you should not have to wear a mask then
you should not have to be wearing a mask
while you're hiking several miles in a
hundred
and hundreds of acres state park right
absolutely it should not be the
requirement you should have one with you
at this point you know at this point
unfortunately it's become a thing that
everyone needs to be carrying with them
your key
you know an id probably some method of
payment and
almost everyone has their damn phone on
them but mask is one of those things you
need to have with you if you're going
out into public but
do you have to have it on your face when
you're when you're outside for the most
part no you should not
and i worry that this new order from the
governor of oregon
uh suggests a creep towards any time you
leave your home you got to wear a mask
right which is going to then send the
you know already huge uh mental health
crisis that is looming
and relatively small i think yet
physical health crisis that is looming
that is going to tip that into a
giant physical health crisis because
lots of people who are still able to run
and bike and play tennis and hike
won't do so if they're if they have to
wear a mask
they may not be able to it may just be
the thing that pivots them from
okay i'm going to get over myself my
activation potential i'm going to i'm
going to do it
to i'm just going to stay how many chips
right it's it's going to be the thing
that makes a difference
and the damn clock is ticking yeah right
it's time if you're going to hike if
you're going to bike this is the moment
right we've got a limited number of
months to do this and the kicker here
is that the vitamin d connection
suggests actually
you better make vitamin d while the sun
shines right which means if you're being
held back by
anything now the cost is later what does
the cost come in terms of
covered risk right are you going to get
it and how bad is it going to be
so that you want to build up in the bank
vitamin d
so that when you are faced with winter
you're
in much healthier condition from the
point of view of resisting an infection
so we got to get this we got to get this
dialed in and we just
don't have it right we're really
screwing up the
um there's just too much rule of thumb
right there's too much rule of thumb and
there's too much politicizing of it
right
it's become a political issue and we uh
definitely have president trump to thank
for that
to a large degree you know someone who
who goes into public and refuses to wear
a mask
even when everyone else around him is is
doing so which happened
at least a few times in may if i
remember correctly
creates a model for his supporters it
says if
you have something like if you're a real
man you don't wear a mask well
sorry no the virus doesn't care what
your political position is as we've said
many times before
yes and then there's the next phase
which is that for a long time
this intentional conflation with flu
right this is flu-like maybe it's a
little worse than the flu maybe it's
worse than the flu for people who are
very old
no no no no this is a desperate
misunderstanding of the virus we face
and i was going to encourage people um
hey zach do you want to put up that
subreddit that i uh
gave you um i happened i didn't know the
subreddit existed although in retrospect
i should have thought that it might
this is a subreddit of people who have
tested positive you want to scroll down
a little bit
um let's see keep going
stop uh up a little bit okay
here's one of many many horror stories
right i'm only 21 and i don't think i'm
gonna make it
now here's what you will find if you
search this and this is
beginning to be dealt with in the
mainstream press
as well not the not the super big papers
but
um the press is beginning to
catch on to the fact that there is a lot
of life being
lost in people who recover right
that the point is you get back from the
flu and actually i would argue that you
probably have
knocked some of your longevity off but
you recover more or less fully from the
flu
people are dealing months out with
the most terrible mysterious kinds of
symptoms because as they describe it in
this form
accurately this is a virus that attacks
vital organs right it attacks your
circulatory system it creates blood
clots so the point is
the list of symptoms is is huge
and the ongoing hazard to you is also
very large
and we've known for months there have
been stories of
uh respiratory reduced function
after recovery from covid but the
cognitive function
being less in many you know i haven't i
have not seen the scientific paper that
uh that relates this yet
but um many journalistic accounts and
and other anecdotal accounts
of people who say they're they have they
have brain fog
they're unable to find the kind of
thoughts and motivation that they are
accustomed to having and that they had
before they were infected now
of course some of that with regard to
motivation you know
many of us i would say all of us have
have been affected
by lockdown and uh you cannot predict in
advance
what what that will do but um people
reporting that
post recovery uh they don't have the
same brain they recognize from before
tells us exactly as you said and as as
we said back in you know one of the
episodes one through
18 when we were largely focusing on this
that just looking at deaths
is a really reductionist way to assess
what the damage from this
virus is yes it's it it misses it
because the point is if you have a
decade or two knocked off your life by
virtue of the damage done to your
internal organs you want to count that
the fact that you didn't die in the
hospital right is is not the
sum total of the story so let's talk a
little bit about why people are dying
less
and why i would say if we didn't
explicitly predict it it wasn't
it was implicitly predicted by many of
the things we said
the fact is you have a brand new virus
it is spreading like wildfire and
doctors are seeing it in large numbers
right
those doctors are fielding it best they
can based on the next nearest
phenomenon that they know and a lot of
it turns out to have been
counterproductive
or ineffective and they learned
right they may not even fully understand
what they have learned some hospitals
may have learned better than others
but doctors in contact over the internet
will have exchanged information and they
are getting better at dealing with covet
patients and we highlighted early on in
late march and and mid early to mid
april uh for instance some a few doctors
saying i'm not sure ventilators is the
right way to go this doesn't look like
that kind of disease why have we
why have we formulated it that way and
uh this this to your point
that it could well be that in fact
care for people with this disease is
simply getting more effective
care for this will get more effective it
will continue to get more effective
another thing that happens is
evolutionarily hosts get
less affected by disease now the
evolution that accounts for that is
primarily on the host side
the virus may also have an interest in
not damaging the host so much that it
doesn't walk around and spread it
but nonetheless there's also evolution
so in this case
probably there hasn't been enough death
yet to account for this but the idea is
what if you had
some fraction of the population that was
spectacularly likely to contract and die
from
this virus by virtue of some molecular
feature of its
cell surface or something like that then
a lot of those people would have been
caught in the first wave
that means that the those of us who
remain are in the category we are more
likely to be in the category of people
who aren't
quite that vulnerable so can i do one of
these english english translations here
wonderful yeah so um really just to
exactly restate what you just said
but uh there will be some range of
effects for any pathogen
and uh you know let's just make up some
numbers here maybe 20
of a population will be affected very
badly and die no matter what
and another 60 there is some range of
possible effects maybe 20 percent
um you know have almost no no symptoms
at all and those numbers
are not reflective of what's going on
with cove and i just made up some
numbers
but when when the thing first starts to
when the pathogens first starts to get a
population
everyone in that 20 percent who is
infected
will die and those people
are then no longer in the population and
so you will see
that 20 percent shrink and shrink and
shrink over time
such that what the original numbers were
will change and therefore the cfr the
case fatality rate will change as well
and
we'll decrease yeah so don't be misled
by the cfr dropping thing that we were
uh being told a more dire story than
we actually have on our hands this is
actually quite dire
and if you think it's not i would
encourage you to go to that subreddit
and look at the
story after story of people dealing with
terrible symptoms that you just really
don't want to have to deal with and
i must say even though i think we are
incredibly
uh conscious and vigilant about this i
even spooked myself reading this stuff
it was like wow do you just not want to
be in these people's shoes and you know
i hate to say that because i don't want
to add to their burden like yeah you
know we're distancing ourselves from
them but
wow they they are a cautionary tale and
we ought to be thinking very carefully
just as you you and i have said
in some sense we just have game theory
problem after game theory problem and
one of the game theory problems here
is that you know okay the u.s screws up
its coveted response okay the u.s is now
a petri dish in which covet is now
learning new tricks and the rest of the
world is going to have to deal
with the downstream effects of our
botching the
uh lockdown um i mean the rest of the
world does have to although it
now americans can't even go anywhere
like there are only a handful of
countries
i don't remember maybe it's something
between 10 and 15 maybe you know a dozen
countries ish
where americans are allowed to travel at
the moment and it's it's mexico and it's
basically a smattering of island
nations in the caribbean you can go to
ecuador with a 14-day quarantine on the
other end
but pretty much i think all of europe
all of asia
um all of africa are off limits and this
is
this is new for americans right we're
accustomed to be able to go
wherever we want to be it's easy to get
visas if you need visas at all
and the rest of the world has looked at
what we've done and looked at what is
happening
now and said nope we rest the world
largely did a far better job than you
did
and you and your infection are not
welcome here
right which is scary because you know
there are a lot of things that could
happen going forward
one of them is we could be four years
out from a vaccine if a vaccine is even
conceivable here and i do think a
vaccine is likely but
you know the the best experts
in the world of vaccines are not hopeful
about one in the next year
right right um that's not to say it's
impossible i have seen some stuff that's
hopeful but there's also hype and it's
very hard to separate those two things
so how long exactly are we gonna go
being unable to travel you know to the
rest of the world
right that's another that's an entirely
different set of costs that we're going
to start paying and it's going to have
profound economic implications so
um anyway and for for those of us
for some of us and it's it's a it's a
small effect
in the global list of effects but have
tremendous mental health effects
oh tremendous mental health effects but
um
yeah i mean look we're talking about a
world we did not prepare for
right and one in which we cannot travel
to other places um
there are things that require travel and
um so there's a question which is really
okay
we just got slapped right we learned a
lesson which is
that bravado stuff was not going to get
you through this by virtue of just
you know bucking up and letting some
people die and
you know we'd get to the other end and
hurt immunity and all of that we're
facing
a renewed nightmare and a renewed
nightmare that we now
have um in some ways fewer tools to deal
with because we've already blown one
lock down and so
yep whatever we need to do now is less
palatable to us
and um so what if we had done you
proposed this
probably first of may okay
uh most of america had already been in
some form of lockdown for
gosh five or six weeks at that point and
you said then first of may
everyone is already exhausted you said
what we need
is an actual full lockdown for six weeks
everywhere that would clobber this virus
and then and then we could actually
reopen well
it would clobber it if you then followed
up properly
yes okay and so if during those six
weeks uh
you were uh generating tests uh
and mass producing tests so that
at the end of lockdown you could do
active test and trace
and actually know who was sick and who
wasn't and not have this sort of
smattering of half-assed tests with high
failure rates and not enough of them and
no tracing
you know we simply a full lockdown
wouldn't have been sufficient but we did
not have
uh an appropriate lockdown and even when
you said this i something like may 1st
not here but you know privately at our
dinner table
my reaction was people won't do it it's
already too late it's already too late
to convince people and that was now
over two months ago right oh yeah we
would have been
long since past that if if we had done
it then
yeah so and this i mean this is exactly
a mirror for frankly for unity 2020.
just wait until 2024 when things will be
what better
you think it'll be better by then it's
not going to be better yes it's already
too late but it's only going to get more
too late
yes it's only going to get more too late
is a i like that formulation i think we
should adopt it because its clumsiness
exactly reflects the clumsiness of our
stupid situation
but yeah the fact is now we need a real
lockdown
and there's no way to do it well i'm
sorry friends we gotta
i i hate to say it but i don't know that
we have another choice because
i mean a this sort of uh bleeds into the
next conversation that we're gonna have
but you know let's do it we've got a
question about
school oh man do we what to do about it
uh upcoming and you know there's
nuance here the very young kids seem
unlikely even if they catch it to
transmit it
so there's talk of letting kids in
uh grade school go back but not high
school
yeah there have i've seen some proposals
and these things are changing daily such
that even what i thought i knew
yesterday i can no longer find online
but
the the conversations in american
schools seem to be
sort of trending towards there have been
very few uh if any cases known to be
have been transmitted in elementary
school and elementary school children
so therefore don't seem to transmit nor
get infected
middle schoolers more so high schoolers
more yet and so there have been
proposals to do things like totally
virtual schooling
for high schoolers at least through
january 2021 some kind of hybrid system
for middle schoolers you know two days
on every week
and then uh in-person schooling for
elementary school kids
uh all of which is horrible
not only horrible horrible but to the
extent that we
let some schools reopen we're playing
with fire
fire that we shouldn't be playing with
right we had we had choices
they are um being eliminated without our
asking them to be eliminated or inviting
it
and at some level
winter is coming i mean it just simply
is right um
so i mean you know i'm speaking as if
everybody lives in the northern
hemisphere which almost everyone does
but i know that there are some holdouts
down there in
australia but if you're in new zealand
well done i should say
well done that was good planning yeah
well done um no no not the people who
had
chose to live there i mean the the
political structure
that that demolished covet 19 in new
zealand oh well i believe well
it was done excellent planning uh for
everybody on
the the islands to to be there and it
was good planning of them to use
effective governance to
do you think you're giving the kiwis
more credit than they deserve
all right now you're the one who's going
to get canceled yes bye
because i call them kiwis yeah yes we
have a new zealand friend she calls
herself a kiwi
yep all right but so here's the thing
you're going to start playing this game
with schools right a not everybody in
those schools
even the grade schools is a kid right
b okay new petri dish we got kids can
the virus figure out how to infect the
kids
right now again this just occurs to me
off the top of my head but
i think a lot of what's going on with
this virus would be well explained
if it had leaked from a laboratory that
was using let's say human tissues
right human tissues that have been
engineered not to hit their hey flick
limits that means special human tissues
like tumor tissues
right that have dysregulation of their
epigenetic nature which means that the
virus would be
in a chaotic set of cells and it would
be learning how to
infect different organs because even if
you took lung
cancer tissue it might be expressing
epigenetic phenomena from other tissues
like liver
so one of the things that might be true
is you know whose tumors you don't tend
to see in
laboratories as experimental material
i got this one do you children children
oh my goodness
yeah so i mean look i don't know how far
this goes but let's just say
one possibility is it's consistent it
doesn't transmit
outdoors because laboratories are
indoors it doesn't uh
transmit to children because the tissues
in question tend to be
um adult tissues it tends to be
you know capable of jumping lots of
boundaries because that's what you would
train it to do
in this in a serial passage experiment
this sounds verificationist and we would
want to you know to
test all of these but these are
predictions from the idea that this is a
lab
this was lab generating their subsidiary
hypotheses that the the nature of the
epidemiology
and the symptomatology is the result
of training a virus in a lab uh both
intentionally and inadvertently because
of the way lab techniques work
so for those of you who are still
thinking maybe it doesn't matter where
it came from because we've still got to
deal with it
no it matters a lot where it came from
it's going to evolve differently
if it if it jumped from a bat or a
pangolin uh that it was then if it was
created especially
from tumor tissues that don't have hay
flake limits which you mentioned
that being um cells that do not have an
endpoint that it could just keep
replicating and definitely those
those cells will act differently and
therefore viruses
that can be transmitted via those cells
will act differently
than any other naturally occurring virus
yeah and the fact is
even if this came from the wild if it
came directly from a bat somehow by some
means we do
do not know we don't know that it did
yet and until we know that it did
you cannot shut down these hypotheses
that suggest this may be a central
player in the epidemiology and the
other phenomenology associated with this
virus so we need to know and if what we
prove is that actually
through some mechanism we don't get it
came directly from a bat
great that would be really positive um
but
um it's not looking likely i gotta tell
you
[Music]
you